take on on what this means at the u.n
and then i know that there's some news
in california that's equally as as
disturbing and idiotic
well it's nakedly political and i don't
know who's telling joe biden what to do
i don't know if it's jill biden kamala
harris the ghost of corn pop but
whatever whoever's has his ear is
clearly telling him to go in that
direction he's taken a 10 point drop in
his public opinion approval rating since
the debacle in afghanistan and if
controlling arms and trying to bring
about world peace is what you're about
then for heaven's sake don't give the
taliban weapons and tanks and
information like it's halloween candy
but this is in the tradition of what joe
biden and his administration does go
back to the fast and furious when he was
vice president of the united states and
they were doing the same thing by giving
guns to the mexican drug cartels his
departure secretary of health and human
services javier becerra when he was
running the california department of
justice it was his job to take guns away
from people who shouldn't have had them
because they were on probation they had
restraining orders out against them
whatever he didn't take the time to take
guns away from them because he was suing
the trump administration they don't care
about taking weapons away from dangerous
people they care about making the left
base of the democratic party happy and
you know we've seen speaking of that
you've got san francisco and
from what we're told
they are now uh wanting to pay the worst
of the worst to not shoot other people
you'll get like a 300 gift card do you
think that's going to solve the
mentality of gang members and others who
are inclined to to shoot their way
through life
well it's ridiculous and it's not only
that they're also willing to pay you
three hundred dollars if you don't get
shot
and
an additional
two hundred dollars if you're willing to
be an ambassador whatever the heck that
means um no but this is this is what
they're forced to do if you're not going
to fund the police department and you're
not going to keep people locked up who
you know are dangerous then you're going
to have to find ways to plead with them
to stop doing what criminals do and one
of the things that criminals do is they
shoot people you know this is it's like
another bribery we've got the bigger
scheme of that with biden and the
taliban and we got the miniature scheme
of it with san francisco uh and the gang
members and the and uh the criminal
elements johnny uh we've got you've got
to get that recall going there you got
to make that work so we can send a
message to the country thank you for
joining me tonight i appreciate it hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else